Every day you move
about 37 trillion cells are working
hard inside your body to keep you going.
These cells are constantly replicating,
living and dying as directed
by your deoxyribonucleic acid,
your DNA.
What if one day you suddenly lost it?
Would you feel anything at all?
How long could you stay alive?
This is what if,
and here's what would happen if your
DNA suddenly disappeared for a start,
you'd lose weight just a third
of a pound or about 150 grams,
not the best weight loss strategy.
DNA isn't just a series of
perfectly structured molecules.
It's your body's library.
It stores your genetic information and
tells yourselves how to grow and function.
The moment your DNA vanish from your body,
you likely wouldn't notice a thing,
not until your body started dying cell
by cell and you became a walking ghost.
How long do you think you would last for?
Think of radiation poisoning?
Gamma radiation destroys your DNA,
but you don't die from it immediately.
Your body still works or your
immune system slowly collapses.
The same thing would happen to you if
all your DNA disappeared to keep you
alive.
Your body cells constantly replicate
themselves by dividing nearly 2 trillion
cells divide every day.
Some of them like your bone marrow cells,
which are responsible for producing
blood divide more often than others.
They all need instruction from
your DNA to function properly.
Without those instructions, they just
stopped working on the bright side.
No one would be able to steal your genetic
information to violate your privacy.
What? After 24 hours without a 100
billion new cells producing blood,
your immune system would collapse.
At this point,
even an ordinary infection could kill you.
After five days,
all of the cells lining your stomach
would die out to your body would be unable
to digest food. You'd suffer
from gastrointestinal disease,
resulting in nausea, heartburn,
bloating, and constipation
and say goodbye to your hair.
Since your hair follicle cells would
stop reproducing. In a normal state,
you lose about 40,000 dead skin cells
per hour without being able to generate
new cells. You could scratch your
skin right off within a week.
Luckily for you, you wouldn't last long
enough to experience those horrors.
Rapid infection or system wide organ
failure would kill you within days,
possibly even hours. You Die,
writhing and abdominal pain,
dizziness and nausea.
The good thing is no one has
ever lost all their DNA yet.
Okay.